qui
bonsoir bonsoir des bonal l'actualité
internationale du jeu d'échecs ce soir
avec deux invités de qualité puisque je
reçois par deuxième fois josé de sousa
ainsi et surtout du nord du portugal et
un éviter tout à fait exceptionnel ce
soir puisque je reçois un grand maître
un grand maître bulgare
il s'agit du grand maître international
nicolas spiridonov bonsoir nicolas
peut-être qu'il y avait peut-être un
petit bonjour à nos amis qui nous
regardent en bulgare ou en russe
oui peut-être vous le dire un petit à
petit bonsoir en russe
non alors nicolas nicolas
vous êtes grand maître international et
vous avez été entraîneur de veselin
topalov et aussi de thiennes macro et ça
fait combien de temps que vous
vous avez entraîné un pic à dire
continuer sa carène ans quand il a
commencé à faire des tournées en espagne
dont c'était beaucoup avant l'été au
fond donc tant par la tribune mais
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que donc
nicolas est avec moi un cahier ça et
c'est pour ça que l'équipe de calais a
gagnent tous les ans on papa tous les
ans mais presque le championnat jeunes
grâce à nicolas parce qu'il prépare très
bien des jeunes et donc comme il a
préparé topalov un grand entraîneur en
fait là nous avons ce soir est pour les
je crois un grand entraîneur parce que
pour rappeler que vous céline topalov
donc aujourd'hui moment elle n'est tout
meilleurs joueurs du monde il est d'un
dif dans les dix premiers joueurs
joueurs mondiaux pour la maison quand on
est un joueur de qualité qui soit donnée
dans les meilleurs joueurs du monde
aussi voilà ce qu'il faut vous avez
lembeye leur en ai un jeune
d'ailleurs on parle d'actualité qui
vient de finir autour de messi qui est
accueilli sa et qui finit premier
français et il a 15 ans et c'est un
élève de nicolas qui s'appelle plantes
et sébastien plante est bon mais je
crois félicitations on va peut-être
d'avoir parlé du prochain match kasparov
planté ça va peut-être arriver donc
l'actualité cette semaine josé c'est
donc ces fameux tournoi allemand donc le
3 de francfort qui gagne le guen
kasparov et à partir de donner un os 32
remonte alors qu'est ce qu'on peut dire
de la prestation de kasparov à francfort
on a fait un peu parler c'est bon
c'était sait bien qu au cfc très fort
c'est j'avais dix sept à neuf et miss me
dire qu'il était très fort et c'est
normal moi je pense qu'ils aient gagné
le tournoi parce qu'il s'est beaucoup
préparé et puis donc il a récolté un peu
les fruits de son travail
donc c'est tout à fait injuste c'est
tout à fait normal je pense qu'on pense
nicolas
qu'est ce que vous en pensez je pense
que bien que lou pas classe
s'accroissent et actuellement il est
vraiment le plus fort joueurs et qu'est
ce que vous pensez de là vous avez vu le
résultat d'un karpov termine 4e qu'est
ce que vous pensez de cette prestation
simplement des défis mais ce n'est plus
le même car prouve qu'ils étaient il ya
vingt ans c'est pour ça qu'on ait pas de
lui jeter la pierre en disant c'est
normal à l'air d'être fatigués c'était
un peu il est peut-être un peu tombé
l'art est un petit peu peut-être les et
chacun oui bien sûr qu'il ne travaillait
plus comment vont ils préfèrent
maintenant je veux car demain il est
fatigué en effet il n'est pas
on ne peut plus être très fort comme oh
oui mais il reste il reste onze ans a
passé son temps est passé mais il reste
quand même un des meilleurs joueurs du
monde métallos bien sûr ces équipes donc
la nouvelle en fait qu'il n'en est
peut-être pas une honte alors finalement
puisque effectivement bon je crois qu'on
s'est un peu tous d'accord sûr que le
fait que bombay karpov va devoir céder
la main non mais pour l'instant il est
encore le champion du monde officiel de
la fédération internationale et
l'information qui a transparu un peu
cette semaine c'est sa présence à las
vegas qui n'étaient pas sûrs et une
lettre officielle est parue sur le site
de la fédération comme quoi finalement
il y aurait quand même jouer ce
championnat du monde officiel à las
vegas et
mais après des informations il
semblerait qu'il a nié il a finalement
dit que ces deux noms
l'information n'est pas encore
officielle
vous en pensez quoi encore je trouve que
le carton c'est quand même un roi delà
de la politique dans le dans le monde
des échecs
oui on cache ses projets mais comme aux
échecs il très prophylactique
il prépare bien ses coûts et puis
peut-être aussi politique
c'est parce qu'il va tenir donc c'est en
tout cas c'est un coup dans le style de
cartons oui on a conditionné son aide a
fait croire peut-être qu'il y aller puis
quand on lui dit alors si vous y allez
non mais j'attends je vois ce qui se
passe je suis pas sûr que la position
soit mûr on va attaquer dans le temps
certains kasparov lui l inverse il ya
bon il a rompu les liens et puis
maintenant alors justement ça nous
ramène justement à kasparov et ça nous
ramène à la partie 2
aujourd'hui nous allons voir une partie
donc du tournoi de francfort donc à
gagner
kasparov contre le numéro trois mondial
vladimir kramnik une jolie partie
on va pouvoir voir alors je vous
rappelle que pour suivre avec nous que
cette partie vous pouvez aller sur notre
appelé de java qui est de positionner
dans la page html en cliquant sur le
petit bouton où il ya écrit joué
vous pouvez aussi charger le fichier des
partis pour le voir sur un logiciel qui
permet de voir des partis et gnc un
logiciel de ce type là vous est proposé
dans notre page dans la rubrique
émission voilà alors nous allons tout de
suite passé à 7,7 par qui
kasparov donc contre kramnik le numéro 3
mondial
kasparov a les blancs et ils démarrent
par le coup eux quatre donc un coup
caspar 6 tout jouer je crois que y'a pas
grand chose à dire
ce début de la partie il est à l'aise
sur quatre sur des quatre le fait il est
très bien préparée surtout donc n'y ait
pas de nouveauté la fin alors pense que
il doit il se prépare en fonction des
adversaires et donc à la fois on a fait
la partie kasparov anand venant à nantes
kasparov pardon ou castorf avais je
pense bien choisi la grande faible pour
contrecarrer le style très positionnelle
d'aaland
et puis je pense qu'il choisit en
fonction de ses adversaires il sait que
krainik joue la sicilienne ski et qui
provient du coût 4 c 5 et il a peut-être
concocté un petit petite nouveauté ou en
tout cas de nouvelles idées
si chaque préparation être une vidéo
personnel adapté pour vos adversaires et
on peut parler aux jeunes eux donc
l'ouverture
il étudie d'autres possibilités mais
concrètement beaucoup donc de
psychologie en fait oui de concrétiser
et a beaucoup depuis votre écologie ou
qu'est ce que vous faites et l'effort
mais 1,93 écologiquement environnement
déstabiliser son adversaire
à l'époque côté fo était fichu projet
que c'est un peu mais d'ailleurs même la
dernière fois dans la partie donc
mentionner la dernière émission donc à
nantes kasparov
on voyait très bien que kasparov a joué
une ouverture qui tout de suite prenait
à la gorge à nantes et voulait pas le
laisser manoeuvrer et donc alors que
cannes on aime beaucoup des positions de
manoeuvre par exemple et donc à sport en
fait tout de suite aller attaquer le
centre le déstabiliser on va voir
comment on se déroule cette partie donc
une ouverture qu'on appelle sicilienne
il secoue de côté l'adoption qui
contrôle une case centrale ici cette
case l'incident des cards ont contrôlé
par le pew voilà en fait moi j'aime bien
la continuité donc les donne à fond on a
parlé du centre
et là c'est toujours d'actualité
toujours dans les parties des grands
maîtres bien regarder le centre la case
de 4 donc si tu peux vous montrer la
case de 4 la case 5 la case des 5 et la
casse des 4 et tous les coups sont
jouées en fonction de ces cas ce qu'on
regarde la partie des andes
kasparov ou celle ci aujourd'hui et je
pense que on peut regarder toutes ces
parties ça sera toujours comme ça alors
qu'elle soit on continue par un coup
logique de développement on va voir un
petit peu les coûts du début on va les
passer commande passée d'écouté au 20
mai toujours regardé les quatre
centrales il toujours il contrôle les
cases et plus important la kf3 qui
contrôle le centre kramnik joue un coup
aussi aux logiques développe une pièce
vers le centre kasparov joue encore un
vers le centre qu'avait disposition pour
compte alors qu'à centrale là je pense
que déjà c'est un petit finesse
d'ouverture puisque normalement
ici on joue des deux des quatre le coût
des deux en d4 et en jouant qu'avait
laissé 3 il est vite peut-être par
exemple je fais ce nikov que krainik
peut jouer par exemple l'idée vite il
évite certaines variantes c'est un donc
un joueur comme nicolas très fin très
fin psychologue et donkey anjouan qui
secoue la cet ordre de coûts il évite ce
qu'il n'aime pas et ils rentrent dans ce
qu'il aime donc je pense que je crois
qu'il faut noter aussi que kramnik crois
qu'il est un expert mondialement connu
de le smic voyante les oriente la gauche
n'aura pas l'occasion d'en parler
aujourd'hui mais est vite et vite cette
variante ou alors bon la rend très
difficile donc il faut alors voyons ce
que fait maintenant donc ravi vous
écologie que 17 ans des 6 mai donc là il
joue sa deuxième ouverture la cécilienne
qui est on va voir très bientôt alors
que sparrow maintenant joue le coup en
déca n'en peux plus rentrer mon à éviter
cette branche et nicole
alors on va donc rentrer en hausse entre
kasparov réplique au cinquième coup part
car il prend des cas des coûts encore
tout à fait logique et la chronique joue
encore un coup vers le centre il
développe son cavalier entre landais
case centrale et alors ça ça s'appelle
finalement disons la sixième des quatre
cavaliers
voilà ce qui commise et nicolas ce qui
est un peu ce que ce qu'a voulu forcer
kasparov donc maintenant il ya plusieurs
coups et kasparov choisi la route ou g5
qui instaure tout de suite une pression
sur les caisses des cavaliers ils
menacent de rendre ce cavalier et les
noirs sont obligés de prendre un pion
cassant leur structure de piau voilà
entre autres c'est pourquoi l'élément
joue le coup ensuite de normal de
l'enveloppement recettes en six
contrôles en cavalier avec la dame est
signée temps vous êtes aussi le but des
noirs dans cette ouverture c'est de
jouer des cinq de se libérer d'un
sicilienne c'est valable dans beaucoup
d'ouverture qui proviennent de quatre
médailles dans la cécilienne donc si on
vient juste un petit peu en arrière on
menace souvent de jouer des cinq pour
contrecarrer au centre voit un jour ou
l'autre et non sujet sain qu'un jour
peut permettre d'enlever le cavalier si
c'est donc une protection de la caisse
des cinq donc là et choisissent donc de
coût 7 6
la crise par an se joue un coup de dé
veloppement la dame en d2 permettant de
faire le grand roque de mettre le roi du
grand côté est activé sa tour vers le
centre de suite vous pour essayer de
peut être d'attaquer les accidents c'est
le but de cette seconde s'est attaqué le
faiblesse des six essais la vente
richter rosaire qu'on appelle se
développe m'en fous j'ai cinq dames des
deux corps oc&c richter rose avant
d'entrer son nom au type oeuvres et je
crois que c'est donc de nom fait de deux
grands jours les échecs et ses fusion de
ces deux noms
voilà au salon le cou à cette a6 a un
double intérêt
sûrement c'est d'abord empêché un
cavalier de venir sur cette case et
aussi peut-être de jouer le coup de
cette baie cinq plus tard
pour la menace pour les blancs cavalli
sur la classe b 5
oui ou non relève kébé saint roch où
croupissent en fou prend 1,6 et
l'identifié comme soulim est cinq
attaquants olympiens des six dans des
idées europe aussi je n'ai pas peur et 6
des mesures en même temps
pas plus tard cette action les deux
bassins pour venir en personne protégée
par ses pions oui est prête pour le pôle
déjà colombo que les pouilles les pépins
ab nous vous souhaitons un jouet voilà
que vous allez les blancs donc nous
serons venus sur le grand côté
le concept des 5 sera d'actualité pour
attaquer c'est le roi est d'ailleurs ce
genre de coups sont du coup qu'on
appelle prophylactiques et c'est
l'apanage des grands maîtres c'est à
dire les grands maîtres on connaisse
aime bien je les coûts profil été comme
ça et là justement s'empêche qu'avait
db5 et s'amène et ça
système et non partisan et
c
justin touristes
une soirée dont
donc souligner comment fait tic à cette
a6 empêche les blancs d'avoir des
manoeuvres sur cette case des cinq vit
en même temps à terme comme disait
nicolas prépare le contre jeu sur le roi
blanc alors valoir mes talents kasparov
logiquement fait le grand roque cramique
mettait un pose la question jusqu'où a7
a6 il demande aux faux bond mais
maintenant qu'est ce que tu fais est ce
que tu t'es change contre le cavalier ou
est-ce que tu pars parce que là ils
estiment que ce fou le gêne un peu
sûrement et il a envie de lui dire bon
mais choisis ton côtoie la cei sont
développées tél ainsi par exemple
kramnik effectivement avait joué le coup
fawcett le flou
le fou alors voila si celle ci après le
coup fou prend cavaliers six chroniques
avait repris du fou maintenant on fait
qu'avec des processus souci celui ci
voit le cavalier siens des quatre
auraient pu prendre ces 6es la dame
finalement aurait pris le pion le pion
des six donc il aurait été obligé de
prendre du plomb et ce qui aurait été
dommageable
éclaircir la situation tout à fait
encore un coup alors la case sport
choisi de ramener son fou vers le
syntras foods 6 c'est souvent en binôme
avec zazie et
m
attaquer l'europe a les deux il ne peut
pas ouvrir une cour aujourd'hui derrière
le jeu et ça les 5 les secrets de 7,2
façon
le tout alors qu'avec le courage 6,6
éplucher et qu'il s'appelle d'ailleurs
le coup du bélier c'est à dire il joue h
6 donc il fait une faiblesse et
maintenant on en voit le bélier g4 g5 g4
g5 attaquant lecavalier le pion et on
ouvre les portes finalement finalement
sur les noirs prennent soin les blancs
mais du coup la coloniser et ouvert donc
c'était le pouce et du bédié donc c'est
un désavantage donc c'est un peu nicolas
le désavantage de secours un petit
avantage en métal en granit choisi de
développer maintenant sont fous qui
n'était encore sur sa caisse de débat
sur la case 17 alors l'avantagé que ce
contrôle aussi le cavalier sûrement et
permet de jouer le coup bessette b5
c'est une baisse qui pour l'instant a
été impossible parce que lecavalier
était en prise avec le cavalier en d4
donc v7 b5 et peut-être b4 après pour
créer des problèmes ou appliquée le plus
de cas fait les halls et noir réagissent
tout de suite cherche tout de suite a
perdu contre jeu plutôt que mais l'autre
variante fouet cette est aussi possible
c'est à dire le développement du fournet
7 est une autre variante leurs fous ici
aurait pu aussi venir en cette
possibilité même cavalier prend des cats
également possible
l'attak blanche tu n'es du roi et plus
rapide pour cent les mains ne sont pas
toutes ces trois jeunes tout de suite à
voyager en chine
quant à la taille de tapis mais ça fait
sept ans développons de voir mon héros
le roi reste au centre aéré 10 mai et je
dois à propos de c'est à dire que
nicolas chaque fois qu'on joue par
équipe me dit le contre je c'est la
chose la plus important alors donc tout
de suite agir tout de suite cherché
contre jeu une patte cc étouffés parce
que là donc on voit que comme on a dit
le coup du bélier g4 g5 et donc pour
prévenir cette action tout de suite on
ici le contre je alors on va voir ce qui
se passe alors kasparov solidifie son
centre de f3 et ça permet aussi de jouer
après g4 ou du bélier je suis un double
avantage ce coup de contrôle à la fois
le pion et permet éventuellement
effectivement le coup g4 et g5 qui
ouvrirait la position et semble arriver
que si tu y vas ça doit empêcher le noir
de se dire je vais faire le petit roy
qui vont ils vont attendre un peu on la
chronique l'ins tout de suite ceux
contre attaque exactement maintenant lui
même sur le roi adverse avec j'écoute b5
menaçant sûrement de faire des coups
comme b4 essayer de créer menace dans le
cas inverse juste comme précision f3
était aussi un petit coup prophylactique
parce que il aurait pu essayer de jouer
h3g 4 mai la jouer f3 pour dit
solidifier le contrôle de quatre parce
que le qatar est efficace très sensible
et en jouant f3 après b5 bi 4 voilà on
attaque ait eu depuis le clavier aurait
dû bouger et le pion aux quatre ont été
entreprises voient encore là
disons le la prophylaxie est un thème
très important on défend et en même
temps permet d'être d'attaqué
donc avis 3d fourcade et permet j'ai
créé pas aussi wall ag car existe donc
un coup aux multiples avantages mais non
profit active maintenant appris qu'à spa
ont choisi d'échanger ce comédien ces
six chroniques évidemment le reprend
avec le fou
on a l'impression que les avantages du
coup de prises de kasparov c'est
d'ouvrir la possibilité de la dame ici
maintenant d'attaqué
oui mais bon
celui qui me des éléments intérieurs le
jeu il ne passe pas
at et efficace dont en échangeant le oui
en échangeant lecavalier avait déjà des
sept colonnes ici
si je fais pression avec la partie qui a
été présentée dans l'édition espagnole
donc je vous invite à regarder
qui était donc kasparov et karpov un
moment kasparov jouent un très un coup
très élégant e 4 qui ouvre la position
justement parce qu'il a un avantage de
développement il à la paire de fou il ya
une position supérieure et joue aux
quatre pour ouvrir la position justement
donc là pareil comme si nicolas et gars
de caractère ouvert pour profiter de son
avantage de développement de
développement alors là maintenant il
joue le coup ce cavalier qui finalement
était sous la menace du pion ici pouvait
attaquer il leur cycle sur cette case
pour venir au centre
probablement ceci dit même si ces
étoiles et des quatre cavaliers en d4
cela le fousseret attaqué le cavaly sera
mieux placés en des cartes qu'ils ne
l'étaient en c3 contrôler le sens est
d'ailleurs pour reprendre une référence
à nîmes the beach nîmes the beach choix
disait le centre peut être contrôlée par
les pions ou par les pièces donc on peut
mettre soins cavaliers en d4 soit un
pion nous manque et pied sont au centre
est long le maximum de rayonnement est
d'ailleurs la dernière fois la partie
anand castorf les vues quand un an de
mai le cavalier sur la bande
eh bien il perd très rapidement donc
vous mettre les cavaliers dans
pour avoir un maximum d'énergie voilà
exactement là j'y fais donc pont route
oui mais cavani sur la bande d'usure il
disait même les cavaliers sur la banda
participe et arracher le joueur du début
finalement qui a généralement été aussi
il ya de la théorie moderne du jeu
d'échecs 1
alors la chronique maintenant choisi de
poster sur la dame saddam sur la case c7
peut-être pour ramener sa tour vers le
centre ou peut-être de faire laurent
peut-être que kramis peut faire le
lui-même de grand reporter il a l'air
d'être pas très bien défendu ses lacets
les poissons cette dame a une action
directement sur cette colonne et en plus
il des protège le fossé 6 et protège le
pousse ici et des fois bon empêche
l'ouverture du jeu parce que la dame
peut être mal placé sur la colonne des
donc il a nuancé cette attaque les
attaques sur la colonne s'est défendu le
fils et six donc je vous empêchant le
coût 5
en contrôlant ici la case de 5 empêchant
les blancs de jouer le coup 5 4 5 qui
serait le disons que les temps si jamais
les blancs les noirs arrivent à se
libérer par des 5 et que les blancs
arrivent à leur tour a joué cinq et ils
ne sont pas libérés en fait le jeu des
noirs libéré six sur des 5
il ne peut pas jouer eux cinq faut être
si un échange de pions ou s'ils arrivent
à prendre les quatre points
kasparov au 13e coup joue maintenant le
roi en bo5 ou prophylactiques comme j'ai
déchargé
ça empêche d échec éventuel sur cette
diagonale ici je tue reprendre quand le
roi réussissent enlèvent leur ont parlé
de la colonne c'est tout à l'heure d'un
plat d'art une action sur le condensé et
protège aussi le pion à deux donc un
coup à multiples fonctionne à un coût
profit les ide plus en voir un coût qui
empêchent les attaques ultérieures
alors maintenant kramnik lui maintenant
enlève ce fou en faisant sur la case
bessette permettant la dame d'avoir
l'action sur la colonne maintenant la
dame a une réelle action alors que le à
elle été bouchés par le fou sachant que
le fou sûrement s'est si souvent
bessette rempli le même rôle puisqu'il
contrôle 7
superbe diagonale qui pourrait s'avérer
bien bouché quand même par les pions
blancs donc là maintenant kasparov alors
jouer un coup de diversion un petit peu
un coup à l'ale ninis ya une espèce de
data quand je vois le coup elle avait 4
et je pense qu'il veut jouer donc son
plan c'est de jouer h4 g4 et g5 et
reprendre g4 et g5 gsm et reprendre avec
un pion sur la case g5 reprendre avec ce
plan voilà pourchassé lecavalier 6 qui
et qui fait pression sur le centre
sûrement l'idée de caspar enfin donc à
plus long terme visant dans la chronique
logiquement augmente son action sur
cette colonne
il avait posté saddam maintenant il met
sa tour et tout de suite on voit pas que
par exemple si la dame venait sur la
case des 4 et bien les noirs pourrait
prendre le pion ces deux avec échec ce
qui serait très embêtant
voilà encore fatal mais très embêtant a
pour l'instant donc les blancs n'ont
plus la même liberté puisque celle dame
ou en tout cas il faut protéger ce qui
devient donc la casse pas rejoint
couvent et qui par étrange il joue sa
tour sur la case h3 non moi j'ai trouvé
une explication est regardée vocation
toujours en fonction de deux plans je
pense qu'il veut jouer donc toujours g4
g5 alors g4 g5 et j'essaie mais sur la
prise h6 pranger 5h six projets cinq
et bien si la tour était resté en h1 oui
et il n'aurait pas pu reprendre du point
4 mais oui puisque la tourache villa
aurait pris la tourache exactement alors
que sur la case h3 elle est protégée là
et si un échange des tours donc si donc
il arrive à jouer g4 g5 et qu' il ya un
échange des pions ashes pranger 5h
quatre projets 5 et 6 maintenant athlé
tour sont échangées et bien le four
vient avantageusement sur la case h3
pour agir sur le centre
et peut-être les nôtres à notre colère
nicolas notre idée
pourquoi quand même jour à gec est fou
de dieu oui parce que ouais ouais là le
rôle du fou à fond il faut enfin surtout
de garder un casque à casque à imaginer
si le colis suspect c'est un sacré
manque à gagner pour se tenir sur la
grèce et 4 mai et changer ce fou se font
de leur mieux pour essayer ribes donc
donc qu'il faut il faut que le milieu
petras affaiblit la position mais le fou
qui se soucient du pck dont le fougueux
petit point donc un double rôle entre
les deux on disait tout à l'heure le
pion f3 un double rôle sur g4 et sur
quatre est là le fou un double rôle
parce qu'ils protègent a classé 4 et
éventuellement la torche 3 dans la
variante très lentement on je ne peuvent
pas son plaisir et j'ai juste une petite
romane jeu je vais contredire mon et
c'est que quand le foot va venir en h3
après les blancs pourront jouer g5 un g6
et puis disons attaqué le pion aux six
donc concrètement alors que sur gk tous
types peut-être qu'il ya des 5 et le
client est roi n'est pas protégé et
laeta tournage 3 je protège le pion aux
courriers demandent donc peut-être que
ces quatre peut-être une réaction
centrale par des cinq évidemment c'est
pas un coup ci ainsi curieux que ça moi
j'aime bien ce courage toi mais
peut-être qu'on en reparlera alors là le
drame unique choisi de bloquer la
possibilité des noirs finalement de
faire ce plan
j'ai deux et quatre en jouant le coup à
6 h 5 mais moi je serais tenté de dire
que ce faisant il a faibli
peut-être sa case ici en gsm s'est
gravement affaibli puisque le fou peut y
aller maintenant alors qu'ils pouvaient
plus tout à l'heure pour les pièces ou
un cavalier ou
donc c'est une corde sensible
mais peut-être que là maintenant il
n'arrivait pas à initier trop de contre
jeu assez de contre jeu pour maintenir
l'activité droit et qui doit parer les
menaces de la loi c'est aïda paris g4 g5
d'ailleurs on avait dit que oui on était
pas obligé de s'occuper des lois ils
pouvaient contre-attaqué au centre et l
dames et maintenant ils étaient obligés
de prendre des mesures
voilà donc de jouer 5 pour empêcher g4
alors voilà maintenant on se fait
maintenant une position de son cavalier
au centre qu'on avait dit tout à l'heure
ses dessins possibilité donc maintenant
cavalier bien positionné au centre la
chronique qui jouent le coup à vaisselle
un peu dans l'idée de ce que disait
nicolas tout à l'heure ses serres cette
fameuse quatre c4 est très importante ce
cavalier finalement mais il saute sur la
case 17 pour venir sûrement 1,5 b6 et
après hop sauter sur la case de ces 4
est proposé peut-être de s'échanger
contre ce fou en tout cas peut-être une
position plus actives en tout cas que
sur la cazelle six ans la kasparov
choisi de mai d'envahir fait dans cette
case faible on avait dit que c'était une
classe faible cette caste g5 finalement
il choisi de poster son fou sur cette
case
alors est ce qu'il ya une idée je pense
qu'elle est dépressif chez évitent
d'empêcher le développement
développement des noirs est alors si les
blacks jouent aussi les noirs joué le
coup fawcett les plantes pourraient le
prendre
l'empêcheur le rock empêchant le rock
note par exemple affaiblissons l'option
des six affaiblissant elle dame comme je
peux peut-être les dames g5 échec
quelque chose comme ça donc on veut bien
placé qui contrôle les cases dans le
sens inverse et qui empêche le
développement en nicolas
en 108 voilà sept tours là ne joue pas
finalement faire le désavantage pour les
noirs c'est que si ce fou ne n'arrive
pas à sortir cette tour où n'a pas de
jeu alors gagné blanc vont jouer avec
une tour plus active et aussi autre
chose le roi restant d'éviter ça c'est
nicolas l'a souligné les noirs ont
initié un contre joué la halle dame mais
ils ont laissé le roi en est vite hélas
le roi est dans une petite cage parce
qu'il est plus beaucoup de gazon et
surtout mais cette tour effectivement ne
joue pas à son client une pièce très
importante n'est pas en jeu voilà si
kasparov lui arrive à activer cette tour
pour l'instant je veux pas trop non plus
mais s'ils arrivent à l'activer il va
avoir potentiellement une tour de plus
finalement qu'on peut se demander s'il y
avait 17 était le bon moment
peut-être qu'il fallait jouer fouet 7 et
continué le développement mais bon c
c'est un coup c'est une proposition
alors on voit maintenant alors kramnik
essayer de trouver une autre idée en
jouant le coup g7 g6 peut-être pour
mettre son fou sur l'a47 que le plan des
six très faible mais c'est la seule et
unique façon de développer son fouet
donc il a le choix il n'a pas le choix
alors cette case maintenant vous pouvez
remarquer nicolas cette case même si
certains est faible les plus protégés
par un pion cavalli bouche par exemple
peut imaginer le couffo aussi ce qui
oblige la tour à bouger et ça y est les
morts ne peuvent plus rauque et et
position très affaibli
et jo j'ai condamné à rester ici et si
les bleus arrivent à percer le mur ici
des pions adverse ils ont réussir à
monter une attaque
voilà kasparov a ça y est maintenant que
en fait les menaces de place 48 j -cr
amené à se fournir à s'affaiblir et
maintenant il revient et maintenant
c'est le tour au ghana c'est tout voilà
ils lavent sûrement bouger ce fou et a
prépositionné ça tend vers le secteu
mans dans ces parties très stratégique
on voit bien parce que je trouve trois
menaces hop il affaibli le camp des
noirs et puis ils vont ternir revient un
jour
disons que la tourache 3 accompli son
action alors la chronique choisi son
moment là pour essayer de se libérer
avec le coût des cinq finalement il
enlève cette faiblesse potentielle du
pion des 6es et menaces des échanges au
centre mais là nicolas une très belle
théorie parce qu'il dit que lorsque la
position n'est pas mûr il ne faut pas
l'ouvrir et là il semblerait que les
blancs soient mieux parce que le roi est
au centre il n'est pas le rendement est
au centre
les noirs ne sont pas développés et
crame ni couvre donc c'est un petit peu
contre le cours du jeu je trouve cet
article alors qu'on appelle ouvrir
peut-être on va on va ramener les
conseils c'est à dire qu'ils proposent
aux blancs de faire un échange entre
mais ça ouvre tout de suite des coloris
colonnes ici pour l'étourdir l'entourent
appareil pourra venir créant des menaces
sur le roi de l'air c'est ce qu'on
appelle donc ouvrir le jeu permettre
pièces lourdes
mais on dirait pourtant que c'est un
coût qui libère les noirs puisqu'après
des six dessins avec les noirs vont en
voir un peu plus d espace mais peut-être
il fallait plutôt jouer bon plus
passivement et puis c'est tenir je ne
sais pas de bons conseils mais j'ai 6
mais pas tout de suite mais c'est
peut-être aussi oui c'est ça me met en
colère
ensuite développé le fou ensuite on sait
5 par exemple oui donc c'est peut-être
une erreur de la part de kramnik s'est
pas non plus mais non j'ai peut-être
plus aux idées voilà il aurait pu
peut-être dû jouer d'abord le coup
d'essai avant d'avoir affaibli sa
position de secrétaire
il serait peut-être été moins moins
dommageable que dans cette position là
on peut noter que tous les pions noirs
censure cases blanches a6b 5
ici la casse des cinq ou six f7 g6 et h5
ça veut dire que les noirs sont
potentiellement ce qu'on appelle faible
sur le casse-noix rend maintenant
essayer blessé blanc qui va changer les
clés fougueuse noir c'est une très bonne
opération puisque le seul défenseur pour
les noirs c'est le footsie qui contrôle
les cases noires donc il faut qu'il
fasse très attention
donc tu as compris la stratégie échanger
les fougueusement d'entre eux alors la
casse par endroits choisis dax et ca1
ouvrir le jeu là c'est très logique
puisque il est mieux développer il est
mieux donc ils ouvrent le jeu donc la
cram nick reprend avec son fou on a
quand même le sentiment que se foutent
bien placés ici puisqu'ils contrôlent
ici au centre d'ailleurs comme on dit et
ils contrôlent un petit peu du côté du
roi blanc ils peuvent être s'est un peu
libérée c'est ce qu'on disait mais bon
il a ouvert le jeu donc c'est la
contrepartie d' or comment kasparov
essayer de tirer parti cette ouverture
du jeu alors déjà créé une petite menace
ici ce qu'ils attaquent la dame et on
peut noter que chronique épargne joué le
coup des six que ce pensent sûrement
prendre et le fou il n'aurait sachant
que calais casement sont très très
faible et en profiterait ensuite pour
essayer de les dominer donc la chronique
refuse effectivement de faire un échange
éventuel
il joue la dame sur la case 17 ans la
kasparov maintenant amène de son
cavalier sur la case d3 avec des
potentialités d'ouvrir peut-être le jeu
de la dalle un shu natoora chevron
voilà donc nicolas legrand notre grand
maître ce soir mais annick effectivement
que si la tour vit sur la case de 20 le
pion de 6 et les clubs à reprendre
puisque la tour ferait un échec donc le
fou ici serait en prise avec la dame et
la tour blanche ici ce fou serait
potentiellement emprise est aussi oui et
aussi un peu au 6 octobre ce cavalier
peut peut-être aussi sauté sur la case
as un mécréant des menaces sur la dame
ne l'empêchent aussi le contre jeu avait
dans des tentes
il n'empêche peut être le contre jeu un
peu d'aidé oui les noirs auraient
intérêt à jouer le coup à 5 puis à 4,6
et d'attaquer le rock mais pour
l'instant par exemple juste a vraiment
bien contrôlée par les blancs lecavalier
t en d4
donc si en plus on peut venir les noirs
on essaie de jouer à 5 puisque sur dame
points cinq tours à huit et déjà on
pouvait se venger sur le pion et 2 avant
la limite et de nicolas et deux jeux
suivants
donc le trou à 5 et 6 les blancs
prennent le pion est très joli détour à
la dame sera obligé de partir est
protégé par le full à tour ici pourrait
prendre le pion dans à 2 il pourrait en
reprendre le fou il pourrait prendre le
pion b5 mais disons que ça créerait
beaucoup de contres jeu puisque ça
ouvrir les lignes sur le roi et donc mon
cas sport je n'accepte pas ce jour de ne
pas accepter donc en fait un jour ce
coup cavaliers en b3 et à la fin ils
activent la dame sur chalaronne ici
ouverte il fait un coup prophylactiques
et les gens trop la case de 5 avec la
cavalier et la dame qui empêche la
manoeuvre que tu as cité
voilà je pense alors à mes talents
chronique positions ne sont fous sur une
hausse finalement une si jolie cabane à
l'itie puisqu'ils contrôlent une
diagonale très très longue
petit vélo
donc est très bonne mais justement que
normand kasparov doit l'empêcher donc je
pense que alors qu'à ça rend fou
maintenant voilà le coup qui paraît
logique le coup il faut qu'il faut pas
rater en fait dans cette position parce
que sinon davantage peut passer d'un
corps à l'autre alors le coup food et si
c'est très intéressant parce qu'il
empêche les noirs de faire le petit roi
puisque le roi passerait sur une case où
il sera un échec donc c'est interdit
c'est la désavantage du coup j'ai sept
îles a permis aux blindes d'envahir les
cases noires de ce côté-là ça ben oui
voilà il sait là vous faites cas sauf à
jouer un peu au chat et souris des juifs
ou g5 empêchant fouet cette maurice est
remis en f4 maintenant fou g7 food et 6
donc c'est difficile de la mouvement
pendules des trous d'un côté de l'autre
et comme disait comme chez nikon a
toujours la tourache vite les tours a
chuté toujours hors jeu pour cet os est
toujours en jeu tant que les noirs n'ont
pas réussi à faire le petit roadster ne
peut pas participer aux combats
comment la chronique fait un coup
logique il attaque
finalement ce fonds pour les 6 12 ans
d'âge il va pouvoir faire le petit
rebondit donc tous trois nommés la place
pas enfin l'intérêt de continuer à
garder le contrôle de ses skis dans la
fuite
non c'était croit sûrement voilà j'ai
joué trois autres possibilités
voilà ce que je vois juste avant la
pause cette position là si si les noirs
chauffe-eau la fuite
bon ben il arrive finalement échangé sur
fouet la rocqué mais ils peuvent par ok
on glisse mais pas moins qu'ils pointent
du doigt mais bon ça c'est un artifice
mais ils ont réussi à améliorer la
position de roi mais mais les plus de
cases manquer ce mois son canton le fils
du tout les cases noires et qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire un malheur sur ces
dames chez decca avec la dame d'accord
la tour ces catastrophes s'apprêteront à
80 ferait même même dmb 4 qui empêche
toujours l'europe c'est bon là donc
chronique attaque le fou kasparov le met
sur la case au cou numéro 23 donc qu'à
ça le met sur la casa 3 continuant
d'empêcher les noirs de faire faire le
petit le ce fameux petit rock et cette
tour est toujours en jeu finalement
c'est de rouler si on regarde bien le
facteur stratégique le plus important
c'est le roi est là le roi des blancs
est très à l'abri la jouer profil
éthiquement robin il a aucun danger
le roi blanc devrait bien protégé bien
protégé il n'a pas fait faiblesse même
le fou à 3 donne une défense
supplémentaires option b 2 par exemple -
m6 est en revanche le roi noir est très
très mal parce qu'il est dans une petite
cage il est un peu encerclé puis dans
une boîte comme on dit voilée dans une
boîte et mondiaux luxembourg canton le
jeu d'échecs et puis les blancs contre
les cases prévues l'après tiroirs et on
peut imaginer par le coup un matin deux
coups d'un objet 5
ça me fait donc il faut faire très
attention alors la chronique choisi de
mettre son cavalier sur la case b6 sur
lantourne ses côtés sur cette fameuse
case c4 veut faire du contre jeu il faut
qu'il est ici des contres alors
évidemment si lecavalier venez sur
casser quand elles sont d absolument le
prendre avec le fou puisque sinon le fou
à 3 serait perdu en un pied et après
l'élan les noirs pour faire le petit
rock et ce serait désastreux pour les
bus pour les blancs kasparov choisi de
jouer le clou sur la case d3 maintenant
proposant à sa tour qui ne jouait pas
devenir en jeu ce qui n'est pas le cas
des noirs il reste toujours bloqué donc
toutes ces manoeuvres en fête consiste à
essayer d'isoler une pièce en fait moi
la saison est d'isoler le bleu roi
surtout ce qui est la pièce la plus est
le roi
raison de plus à la cramif choisi de
venir sur l'a 4 6 4 hélas kasparov
forcément me noël le graët ne peut pas
permettre que ce qu'avait d'abord
prendre la dame évidemment c'est pour ça
que le flou voilà devait rester devaient
rester sur la case f1 mais reprendra
alors chronique jouer un coup
intéressant il prend du plomb ces quatre
avec deux chaînes parce que ses forces
aient fait il doit il veut essayer passé
alors oui voilà les pompes et dur voilà
peut-être un jour ces trois comme un
bélier pour essayer d'ouvrir la position
voilà donc il essaie quand même
d'attaquer le problème c'est qu'il va
quand même attaqué quatre ans au 6 mai
81 ans qui joue avec une tour de plus
voilà et cette somme à venir en jeu
alors qu'il y avait ici ne joue pas est
toujours le roi blanc toujours très sûr
alors que le roi des noirs est toujours
une position très difficile
ça c'est un facteur très important alors
la crise par hosni de jouer le coup
cavaliers sur la case des quatre
attaquants la dame noire
et puis bloquant la diagonale le cran la
diagonale
local des banales du froid je suis ici
la halle se font maintenant des attaques
et on peut noter que rien ça bloque et
en plus ce four à 3 un double rôle
encore une fois on a vu beaucoup de
double rôle aujourd'hui on a vu le pion
f3 tout à l'heure qui contrôle la case
katla casier 4 et puis 1,6 contre les
caisses v5 qui me laissait simonet cbc
mais la cbc maintenant ce fou qui
empêche le roi noir de roquet et en même
temps contrôle éventuellement au cas où
la case des deux fruits durs mois et tu
fais bien dire au cas où parce que
souvent ça arrive malheureusement on
oublie et paf
il faut souvent ses skis et c'est ce qui
fait perdre les joueurs on se méfie pas
et puis allemand au large kramnik choisi
de jouer un coup intéressant je vois sur
la case b6 une fine pression maintenant
sur le pont b2 peut-être d'un bessette
et plus précis pour un contrôle à cazaux
cet objet 5 comme cette note n'est pas
possible avec la dame en baisse est
peut-être effectivement de la messe est
née plus plus plus intéressant
peut-être les noirs ont pour idée
d'échangé ici au centre de perdre leur
fou superbe donc là c'est encore pire
dire que si les gens disent il est blanc
et échanger les foules c'est bien pour
eux mais si les noirs dans leur foulée
c'est encore pire puisqu'ils gardent
leur faut benoît leur [ __ ] cases
noires et donc peut-être ils peuvent
s'en sortir d'une finale avec des fous
qui contrôleront camp quand il ya collé
fou oui mais quand y ait des tours ou
des dames c'est et qui est le roi aussi
exposés c'est très difficile pour le
compte plus faibles justement le fait
qu'il est fou que la reposer permet
d'attaquer en nicolas ajouter quelque
chose
opposez vous
lachance d'attac chance
oui c'est les saynètes où seule poche
ouais ouais mais c'est très motivé de
pièces
il ya mieux comme la colère ce qui se
passe maintenant
caspar vous le coup effectivement
peut-être c'est l'autre d'où la
précision du groupe pour ça que damas
était peut-être plus précis j'ai collé
blanc menace maintenant dans cet échec
et mat au prix d'un petit sacrifice
puisque bon anecdotique puisque ils
peuvent bien sûr pas prendre des caves
réunion lé nord pourrait reprendre le
travail il est bon mais il se met à
perdre et laurent puisque dame g5 vient
offs est protégé par le fou et les noirs
ont qu un moyen de prendre la dame le
roi dont seraient donc échec et mat donc
il faut absolument que les noirs mais
par cette menace a on peut imaginer que
kramnik quand même un endroit mondial a
vu le match il va le par et dans
l'instant voile avait choisi le coup
fouet suite finalement quand même quand
même donc il serait donc finalement il
se résout à échanger se fout parce que
des hits est trop fort le coup alors
nicolas produite alors si si le coup
lorsque je vais le 7 pour les noirs par
exemple le coût d'un manque des huit qui
protège la case aux sept cavaliers
progressiste qu'elle ait promis ce sirop
d'amd vie à l'italie pourrait prendre 6
6 et puis on compte d'un projet si c'est
chez ici alors s'il comprend les blancs
auraient pris le plonger 6 avec échec et
ensuite le voilà eric échec encore voilà
le west à différents moments du grand
maître 1 voilà la dame serait temps d ok
ok de dame des miss il faut prendre
cavaliers la tour prend la dame indiqué
cheikh et la dame prend le cavaly pour
reprendre les niveaux même moi je peux
poser cavaliers projet c'est encore
mieux cavani proches et ses échecs on
attaque le roi roi fit je prends je
change la dame
non mais je fais cavani oui en plus on m
a régalé les projets c'est encore
meilleur on va on va arrêter cette
possibilité en tout cas d'alou j'évite
semble un mauvais coup de défense très
peu fou et cuites et peut-être un des
leurs de coups possibles oui on peut
noter peut-être surnomme 17 sept
on peut peut-être kasparov tout
simplement on rejoue le coutour
eux-mêmes menace je t'aime aussi
cavalier f5 peut-être si on va en
kabylie et le 5è très bon coup sûr d'un
bessette voir ce qui se passe sur la
suite des coups mais on va voir ce que
la wii les joueurs ont choisi d'amener
cette cavalière 5 dont qu'aucun numéro
27 de cramique choisi le coup donc
finalement foulée suite
et maintenant kasparov choisi sans fin
enfin il arrive cependant ça y est voilà
buts stratégiques et de l'industrie
tegick est atteint puisque le fou qui
contrôle et les cases noires est mort
mais maintenant il est quasiment dans
plus de défenseurs et les blancs vont
pouvoir s'amuser
on va voir comment ça se passe alors
kramnik choisi de reprendre le fou
logiquement il maintenant kasparov tout
simplement augmente la pression il met
sa tour au centre est tout de suite déjà
une menace de prendre le jaune
voilà par exemple à d'abord g5 ici peut
prendre le fou il est d'avis que si les
noirs essayer de reprendre
il serait en échec de la droite l'option
ici c'est chloé donc c'est un coup
interdit donc la chronique dans
absolument trouver une solution et bien
il crée lui-même une menace juste un
jour autour de 8
il menace lui même ça y est échec et mat
comme quoi les sur la case b2 les fameux
dans le cas où car où mais maintenant le
fou n'est plus là pour protéger ces
notions donc là kasparov choisi de jouer
le coup b2 b3 qui empêche tout
simplement
cette menace est en plus mais les pions
sur la couleur du fond blanc donc
j'empêche de bouchehr ça le fou étant
limitée voilà il imite l'action du fou
adverse en plus donc la chronique
choisit maintenant de protéger son fou
dessin qui était attaquée et à kasparov
joue le coup cavaliers en e2 qui a
sûrement davantage de libérer maintenant
l'action de sa tour et en plus de
menacer peut-être on sait jamais
cavalier f4 peut-être quatre attaquants
le fou attaquant peut-être la case aussi
s'est agrandie et si tu avais aussi la
casse g6 après ils pourront peut-être
poussé g2g cas oui je pense qu'eux mêmes
ils ont besoin or la chronique choisi le
coup il prend d'abord sur le 4 mai 300
lumens des échecs dangereux qu'à sport
tout simplement choisi de reprendre du
pied alors notez que fou prend b3 ici
n'est pas possible alors le sacrifice de
fou fou prendre les trois pour essayer
d'ouvrir la position du roi n'est pas
possible parce que je fais tourcoing de
8 tours je prends avec échelle outre la
dinde est arrivé vite reprend d'un
échange au chili les dom avec échec il
faut heureusement donc toujours été
ensuite on reprend le fou et on a gagné
une pièce belles pièces donc la
chronique choisi le coup tour sur la
case 17
alors là on remarquer en brèche qui
menacent peut-être foot en d3 maintenant
ah oui il ya peut-être cet échec mais en
ferme encore plus le roi on marque parce
que maintenant le roi n'a plus aucune
caisse de sortie il est dans une boîte
totale là il peut plus il peut plus
bouger parce que la dame ne lui empêche
de bouger sur 4 noir ces fermes et dont
les tours l'empêchent de dans les tours
sont très passif puisqu'elle empêche son
propre droit de on peut comparer
l'activité des tours e1 et d1 à celles
qui sont 17es fut noyé à colombes 17 qui
est un petit peu défensive mais c'est
l'enseignant fluide points entre on n'a
pas vraiment d'action dans le jeu depuis
le début de la partie d'un jury
maintenant caspar jouer un coup très
simple le roi en b2 tout simplement très
profite à une très bonne position il
joue un coup qui protège le pion b3
finalement et je profite actuellement
mais il n'a rien à craindre il joue
tranquillement il a le temps et la
chronique je le coude à main sur la
casse des huit attaquants la dame de
caspar en proposant d'échanger et puis
ce qu'il veut c'est de limiter la
pression des trois plumes plus il ya des
changes au mieux s'est politisé la
kasparov choisi
d'éviter cet échange en mettant la dame
sur la case f4 et maintenant chronique
et cède encore d'échanger en fait il
fait une menace en échange chronique il
essayé d'échanger absolument les deuils
elle a essayé de faire nul concédé à la
vie telle attaque est maintenant et
maintenant kasparov fait joue alors la
superbe coup le coût pour prendre des
cinq de kasparov une pré avec moody's
l'avait fait au match et la dame voilà
la dame ici et protégé alors qu'elle est
l'idée de soukouss et que maintenant on
peut imaginer toutes les variantes
l'idée c'est que si les bleus remportent
du pion la colonne ici sourit le si
lecavalier bouge il ya un échec au roi
donc en fait la vraie seule valeur
possible ses pions prend des cinq
puisque surtout reprend des siècles ont
fait d'un prince elle va peut-être voir
les variantes puisqu'on arrive à la fin
justement des hommes très belle partie
si les blancs les noirs par exemple
prennent du plomb donc maintenant
alors maintenant on fait le cavalier ici
bien sûr la case des quatre avec et chef
de la tour alors si les noirs jouer le
coutour aux 7,7 tour ne pouvais pas
bouger à cause de l'échec donc la dame
blanche pourrait prendre la dame adverse
tout simplement et on remarque quand on
prend en plus la tour en 2 20 c'est pas
oui c'est sans être sûr échec c'est le
roi de tous les coups de castor très
très profilé ctic dans le pire des cas
par cas et noir prennent la tour ici et
pas il n'y a pas eu les corons d'occupé
d'eux ont continué leur vision revoilà
donc la version pro tour
le cavalier un d eux devient sur la case
des quatre avec échec de la tour e 1 sur
le roi le roi donc été obligé d'aller
sur la case des vies 18 et la très jolie
coup de kasparov qu'il peut enfin tu
aurais pu jouer c'est le cavalier sur la
case e6 ici avec un échec sur le roi et
attaquant la dame et le tour en effet de
ses impôts est malheureuse et la tour et
suit alors il reste au noir le seul coup
pour éviter de perdre en deux par le
cavalier tacle à même de prendre avec le
pion en et si maintenant la dame elle
apprend la tour et fuite avec échec et
mat
donc c'est pas possible pour les noirs
de prendre avec le pion alors maintenant
une autre coût possible
point noir ce serait de dire je prends
la tour avec la tour mais tout
simplement de dams et ont pris la dame
sur l'emprise possibilité de quatre
chroniques échange des dom haye après il
va dire le après je pouvais reprendre la
tour mais maintenant mais on prend tout
simplement du cavalier on peut pas
prendre la tour du pillon puisque la
tour cyclos de l'option et 6 et la tour
blanche est protégé par le cavalier donc
en cas des changes
le car lille reprend et les blancs reste
avec une pièce de plus c'est un gain
facile pour que dire cette combinaison
est très joli mais elle n'est pas du
tout elle n'est pas du tout elle n'est
pas surprenante parce que dans la mesure
où le roi de cramique tellement faible
on à mesure où les tours est tellement
passive investissions est mûr pour mon
horizon et tenir volaille qu il était
temps de chercher quelque chose alors
kramnik choisi le cookie on prend un
tour des 5 et la catastrophe joue la
variante qu'on a vu qu'à valider quatre
échecs et la granny comprend payer la
vue s'il fait tour cette hyper la dame
avec d'emprunt ces sept là si on ne peut
pas reprendre à cause de l'échec de la
tour s'il joue le roi en des huit
lecavalier bien sûr la case aussi salée
échec au roi attaquant la dame donc il
faut prendre du pied aux cavaliers et
dans ce cas là même pour un échec et mat
avec la tour donc là ça y est qu'après
menée par a compris ce qu'il abandonne
il doit serrer la main de kasparov est
que dès que qu'est ce qu'on fait à jouer
ce truc là avec l'idée de faire ce piège
de gdf d'am dam dam d'ebitda même
qu'adam c7 et je pense qu'il avait vu ce
piège un peu avant comme sur saclay il
est quand même très fort pour placer une
combinaison comme ça en numéro 3 mondial
faut pas craquer voilà je crois qu'on
arrive à la fin de cette partie avoir
évité de citer une très jolie partie
oui je vous remercie de grands maîtres
d'être venu on confond rappeler quand
même on a la chance aujourd'hui d'avoir
eu des analyses de l'ancien entraîneur
de veselin topalov est aussi d' etienne
bacrot qui est nôtre qui est notre grand
espoir national
voilà donc nicolas spiridonov merci
d'être venu nous voir ce soir josé une
prochaine
très bien mais je pense qu'il y aura
d'autres occasions de nous revoir et
peut-être de commenter des tournois
d'ailleurs on va essayer de commenter
des tournois directement à paris en
venant films et des événements comme le
championnat de paris comme voilà donc on
va essayer de voilà bientôt très grand
tournoi 1000 joueurs plus de 1000
joueurs très intéressants à paris je
conseille à la halle carpentier réponse
est oui voilà surfer à paris voilà
bonsoir aussi bon soit un bon soir
nicolas je vous dis au revoir merci à
vous et pourra bientôt pour une
prochaine émission de diagonale